[Music]
welcome to a very special edition of a
beginner breakdown we are back alright
talking about one else the fried liver
two nights the fence which is apparently
better than the fry liver but I am sorry
to interrupt you guys um like I don't
know how to tell you this but we've
decided to go in a different direction
here at the club we no longer are gonna
be doing beginner breakdown it's just
not working out look nobody's coming out
so we're canceling the show man dude the
people have spoken have you read the
YouTube comments
the people's mandate says no more Mike
comer have you not read anything well
who's gonna replace dude anybody could
replace you just like an go out of the
street right now I can find anybody to
replace your mic dude really
alright then come with me listen let's
go I gotta figure this out let's go
oh hey so how are you doing today do we
need you to fill in for a chess class
you know anything about chess today
that's fine that's fine that's cool just
come on in
it's called tactics time you got this
[Music]
[Music]
all right thank you for the warm welcome
wanted to thank all of you guys for
coming out my name is Dennis LaRue this
is tactics time there's gonna be a
series of lectures where we focus on
basic tactical ideas it's gonna be close
and format to begin or break down and
kind of staying true to the roots of the
great tradition of YouTube videos that a
the Chess Club here has been has been
engaged in I'm going to look at a game
essential knowledge for anybody in the
beginner to intermediate level and that
game is the Opera MIT's known as the
opera game between Paul Morphy the
strongest American player of the time
and two French aristocrats Morphy has
the white pieces in this game and the
story is true I was played in an opera
house and he allowed them to consult
with each other these two aristocrats
and he still just destroyed them on and
our goal today is to identify some of
the general positional ideas that are
guiding his guiding Morpheus play the
general positional ideas on and basic
principles that we use and teach teach
beginners but more importantly than that
we're going to try and find the winning
tactics okay so if you've seen the game
feel free to chime in if you feel that
I'm overlooking something important or
neglecting a you know an important
sideline otherwise I hope you guys go
enjoy going over this as much as I
always do I know it's always a rewarding
experience um so we have E 4 and E 5 on
the board and most opening encyclopedias
this this categorized is an open game on
the reason being that the center
typically opens up a little bit faster
and white makes a logical second move
attacking the e5 square here black is a
number of reasonable options the knight
to c6 is what's most often played but
the consultants
picked a move that still gets played to
this day
d6 entering the Philidor defense fine
destroy a strong pawn move that actively
contests the center Black has made it
easy and almost invited white to just
get a nice healthy pawn Center and
establish firm lasting control of it and
so he does that but I do feel it's kind
of important just to see Aaron pause
just for a moment because there are a
number of ways that you can proceed and
students especially in the under 1,000
range I see they all they often want to
make really passive moves here and some
of the better options are like a you
know a bishop move to get ready to
Castle kingside or nice e3 all of these
are played playable but this is the way
to try and gain a lasting initiative and
here blacks black makes a move it I
still see in the casual play area when
I'm playing blitz this was played
against me the other day and I got
really excited because I knew exactly
what to do here and this is another
position where I always ask the students
tell me what what they think is the best
move for white and why so at home you
may want to pause your video this is not
this is far from the toughest but the
point of making a puzzle out of this
kind of position is to really ingrain a
certain way of thinking about opening
and developing in the first few moves
the game so anybody in the audience what
didn't you like about capturing
immediately on e5
did you consider that I believe
everyone's agreed on this being mistake
but why why is this a mistake and
unfortunately a move like Bishop e2
doesn't necessarily illustrate the
concrete variation which shows that this
move is will leave black with a
permanent disadvantage and the move that
really highlights or accentuates that
weakness is to capture immediately that
if black plays the most straightforward
and logical continuation just you know
recapturing here
losing the e5 pond there's a danger of
losing that e5 pawn so if he does
recapture directly it should be clear to
those at home and everyone in the class
at this point that white has this
resource at his disposal you can trade
Queens on the D file breaking that pin
on the knight f3 capture that e5 pawn
okay black sees that between the two of
them they were able to identify that so
like most of us in this room we play
blitz a lot and I see a few of you this
is the kind of decision that we would
make over the board and here you know at
the risk of being overly remedial I
always ask my students how would you
recapture here seems obvious that you
would capture with the Queen but some of
them just haven't quite appreciated yet
that you don't want to double pawns and
mutilate your pawn structure for no good
reason so you certainly do capture with
the Queen here now black can recapture
safely on e5 but White's looking good
here I also pause a lot and I get them
to think about the general ideas in this
opening by bringing up fools mate and
scholars me and I ask them you know what
are the main ideas behind those
obviously you know if they listen to me
they don't they don't try those in
tournaments because they break a lot of
fundamental opening principles you don't
want to move your Queen to h5 you know
on your first or second move which is
what scholars main tools may entail on
but we still teach those mating patterns
to students because they exemplify a
theme or an idea which is always present
sometimes it's just lurking in the
background belt often it's in the
foreground of any e4 e5 opening and that
that theme is a favorite of my comers to
cover and talk about the fried liver
attack it's often referred to as but I
just think of it as an attack on weak f7
um so with that being said I always ask
my students
what's the net our natural and logical
developing move which attacks f7 which
because of the previous line of play is
already under attack by the Queen on f3
we all know that what the threat is and
if we don't now we do because I'm gonna
keep using this cool highlight function
here this pair of French aristocrats in
the late 1800s being a respectable pair
of chess players um aren't too keen on
being checkmate it on move four or five
or whatever this is how do you prevent
that made on that 709 h6 is interesting
because instead of just interfering like
Jason suggestion here he's interfering
with the Queen's action in your
suggested line he's directly of
protecting it right there's just one
little problem that age six square is
under attack so what happens if I just
take that night
right yeah exactly and now a sad day for
black but you know this is the reason
that I you know some of us some of us
may say oh then you know this is too
basic too simple no I mean the morphe
game and all the more if he's more if
he's game had you know plenty plenty of
ideas and stuff to teach players of all
strengths so here is Jason suggested
they correctly interposed the knight on
f6 okay morphe is undeterred he is
determined to put all of his might all
of his force
I'll not it on that f7 square this is
the one where I can tell where you know
to me I use the city to determine how
predisposed he knows it so my students
are to it I tell them find a square I'll
find it find a move that attacks f7
twice again that renews the attack on f7
the Bishop is already attacking f7 so it
can't be a bishop move the Queen was
attacking f7 the knight on that six put
a stop to that it's a queen move find a
queen move but on b3 we are attacking
out of seven the second time and we're
making some other threats as well you
guys feel free to shout him out what
else is white threatening here on the
light squares I'm sorry capturing the
weak b7 pawn right right and its weak as
a consequence of of blacks inaccurate
play in the opening he made a
thoughtless Bishop move which led you
know led to align into in which he was
forced to exchange it for the knight on
f3 and now the light squares are absent
a defender a very important defender
so the problem persists the same problem
ef7 is under attack how does black
address this issue
and definitely at home take some time f7
is under attack we want to defend it but
we've also got another thing to worry
about this is slightly inferior to what
was played in the game okay and I want
the viewers at home and you in the class
to really think about why and if anybody
could tell me at this point that'd be
awesome
not Claudio Claudio knows so this
what are we going to do here with black
is there any way to save that rook
26
right yeah but there's the kind of thing
like the details like Danny's always
saying it's the little details which
make or break it yeah
so you ideas yeah oh yeah say it let's
hear it why why is this better huh
beautiful yeah to me this is the one one
of the main objectives to when I review
this with students is to make sure that
they they can see that that because with
black it the theme is just stubborn
defense yeah you got yourself into a lot
of trouble but you know if white is
careless and thoughtless here
gets greedy and attacks the rook in this
position you can take the steam out of
his attack you'll be down upon but as
the young man in the back of pointing
out you have a forcing little forcing
exchange here I mean obviously he has to
do that right unless he wants to lose
his Queen um you you you've at least
eliminated the right the risk of an
early checkmate which is a risk that
these guys are flirting with and
ultimately they succumb to so lucky
luckily for them though they saw that
more if he being awesome as he was did
not get greedy like myself for many
others at our level would and and take
here thoughtlessly he looked for the
best way to maximize his already
considerable advantage and he followed
just general principled play which as I
said in the beginning is kind of what we
wanted to focus on here we're taught all
these ideas control the center develop
rapidly castle early but often for
whatever reason we wind up neglecting
them in our actual games and one reason
is that we don't train ourselves and
condition ourselves to constantly be
asking ourselves whether or not we're
playing by them on why makes a pretty
good excuse me black makes a reasonable
that at least defensive move he does not
that want that night on d5 it will be a
monster there and so he plays c6 totally
understandable Morphy staying in line
with these basic principles of opening
play which we were just talking about
develops his final piece in the most
active way possible creating a pin and
black starts to panic because some of
the the issues in his in his position
namely the fact that the king is stuck
in the center
so while white is exemplifying
exemplifying good opening play black is
an example of horrible opening play his
king stuck in the centre for the
foreseeable future and he has two minors
still on the back rope or his White has
all of his minors he has this beautiful
development going on all of his minors
off the back and he has the option of
developing on whichever side he'd like
so he panics he wants to get this Bishop
off the diagonal so that he can move his
Queen you know on a good day get that
dark squared Bishop out and Castle
kingside um and he makes this horrible
losing move the name of this class is
tactics time pause your video at home
have you've never seen this what is the
tactical idea here okay well instead of
being passive and retreating this Bishop
he says no this is the cornerstone of my
hold attack and all of my ideas in this
game I will not you know give up this
bishop just LightSquared bishop without
a fight
but this night however is quite
expendable for the price of two ponds
that's fine because one of the the
benefits or some of the conversation
that white will get in return is that
this king will never ever Castle so he
gives up his night gets his check in
there
and I'm sure the players with black
pieces started to get that sinking
feeling in their stomach you know when
I'm in positions like this it's like you
know you almost just start making bad
moves just because you're you know the
momentum is so bad but here to finish
development with light in the most
logical way so what's the last stage and
development typically castling that
castling long kills two birds with one
stone it gets our King safe and it adds
pressure to this absolute pin that we've
created on d7 against the night on d7
with our Bishop b5 maybe for some of the
younger students in the classroom we can
just point out that you know you must
defend this we can't let white capture
in that position on d7 and here we're
near the ends at home go ahead and pause
the video spend a little time thinking
about this how would you proceed with
white and you guys in the class you know
I'd really appreciate some feedback you
know what do we think is best here
so like Mario just suggested take and we
can start to see all of our principal
play play start to bear fruit as it were
this is a pretty forcing move here and
if I'm not mistaken the engine wants you
just to take with the Queen at this
point and not get checkmated but these
guys didn't have engines they didn't
make that losing losing move either um
they made the most logical position and
the most logical move into position
recapturing with this rook here fatally
weakening the back rank and here I will
not go any further than this talk just
for a second about that again we're
renewing pressure on the pin and here
Black is daydreaming
you know he's hoping that you know white
will have a lapse of judgment perhaps
and allow him to exchange Queens or
maybe even initiate the Queen exchange
more if he's not having it he wouldn't
wouldn't have gotten this far I wouldn't
have attained this type of position
without knowing exactly how to proceed
here but me I didn't know how to
perceive him till it was spelled out for
me and you guys need to find what's up
here okay what do you see okay
the knight takes D seven and then what
are you going to play can you see I just
want to work out that calculation muscle
really quick before I put it on the
board all right correct forcing move
Bishop takes clearly and again I think
the engine will just tell you to take
with the Queen here don't get don't get
checkmated um but he takes with the
night because he doesn't see the
beautiful forcing matin one here
made into rather excuse me very
impressed I see a lot of people cheering
back there for you all right good well
done are you sure though you're giving
up the Queen you're positive all right
I'm good I just want to clean with black
pieces didn't I what do you play here
did you keep huh
rook d8 what what do we call that
beautiful okay and that is a forcing
matin - all right I hope you guys
enjoyed enjoyed watching that as much as
I enjoyed going over this classic and
timeless game Paul Murphy's opera game
hit like share subscribe I'm very open
to feedback you guys let us know well
you well you'd like to see me cover in
this new series tactics time that we've
got going on okay thanks a lot
[Music]
you
[Music]